I I just want to know because I don't
know the story you auditioned for Wes
Craven for the scream stuff yeah how
many times
first time is for Lisa Beach back in New
York no it's here CBS Radford
and she was looked at me the whole time
and she's like
that was really good
and like you know people say that but
you don't know right and then she goes
could you come back Thursday to meet the
director and I said
yeah are you serious she goes yeah
and then I left and I didn't you know
didn't know it was gonna reel or not and
Katie Mason my agent
called and said honey you're going back
Thursday so then I went back met Wes
very quiet yeah I worked with him too
yeah did the scenes and then he was like
that was good
and I was like
does that mean it's good he's like that
was really good and so then I was like
boom then did you know all your lines
inside out no that's what's great bro
you can look at my audition tape I'm
holding the script I'm looking down I'm
improvising do you remember when
directors like Wes why they're the
greatest because they play it was an
audition it was play and he saw yeah he
saw in essence Dave when I got three
kings David Russell made me read for
three different characters he goes go to
the bathroom and learn new stuff okay
and come back man I don't like that go
to the bathroom and learn this one but
you didn't learn it you kind of just I
just did it and then we improvised we
did it Essence it's Essences hey there
folks it's Michael Rosenbaum and boy
have I got a huge announcement for you
this has been a long time comment and
it's finally here I'm doing a live
podcast my podcast inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum is going live yeah for
the first time ever on Wednesday October
11th at the iconic Regent in Los Angeles
and guess what I'm not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs and sites and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
you know now if you miss one line on a
[__] self tape on a zoom you're dead
to them it's like I I mean that's the
difference between autors and corporate
you know creative of art corporations
can't make art authors do you know Wow
TV art is not made by committee that is
my opinion so it's made by singular
Vision so I went I auditioned and then
the crazy [__] is is that
I was filming Romeo and Juliet
and they my agent called and says I have
two auditions for you next Saturday I
was like six weeks down there and they
go you gotta get back here but they're
not flying you back
one was a screen test for a movie the
past
and another one was a movie called
scream
and I went in and I killed at the past
and then I went for scream and I think I
did really good but my hair was pink
and the whole there was like eight
people in the room and they were like
and I remember Marianne and she's like
your hair
it's pink
and I go I know and she goes why and I
go because I'm doing Romeo Juliet I'm
doing with Leo Leo you know Romeo and
Juliet is gonna be in big bass and she's
like Okay and like I'll just was like
I'm gonna lose this [__] job I'm like
we could die I'll pay for the die job I
can diet you know what I mean like I'm
rapping in two weeks
long story you know long we tend
podcasts to tell you how I got the job
but it was getting it losing it getting
it losing it getting it losing it Wes
loved me the producers love me the
studio one in the name I wasn't a name
back and forth back and forth and then
Wes God Rest his soul you know he said
this is my guy